la ley de hu nos dice cómo calcular una
fuerza ejercida por un resorte ideal o
lineal y también nos dice que esa fuerza
será proporcional al estiramiento o
compresión de un resorte a partir de su
posición de equilibrio o longitud
natural y la fórmula nos dice que la
fuerza elástica del resorte es igual a
la constante de elasticidad por la
distancia del resorte que se estira o se
comprime y observen que esta equis no es
la longitud del resorte sino más bien
que tanto se ha estirado o comprimido a
partir de la posición de equilibrio
veamos un ejemplo supongamos que un
resorte ideal cuelga del techo y en
reposo tiene una longitud sin estirar el
e1 pero cuando una masa m es colgada del
resorte y el resorte se estira ahora
tiene una longitud l 2 cuál es la
constante de elasticidad del resorte
bueno la fuerza de gravedad tiene que
estar equilibrada con la fuerza elástica
eso significa que la fuerza elástica del
resorte es igual a la fuerza de gravedad
y sabemos que la fuerza elástica es
igual a ca por x donde x no es l1 l2
sino que tanto se ha estirado el resorte
a partir de su posición de equilibrio
por lo tanto es igual a l 2 - l 1 y si
despejamos que nos queda m g entre l 2 -
l 1
qué es el movimiento armónico simple
bueno decimos que una variable es un
oscilador armónico simple si cambia de
acuerdo a una función seno o coseno y
esta función se ve así
la variable cambia en función del tiempo
que puede ser la posición vertical de
una masa en un resorte el ángulo de un
péndulo o cualquier otro oscilador
armónico simple y eso es igual a la
amplitud del movimiento que es el
desplazamiento máximo a partir del
equilibrio por el seno o el coseno de
dos pi por la frecuencia del movimiento
por la variable t y como la frecuencia
es uno entre el periodo lo podemos
escribir como dos pi entre el periodo
por el tiempo y como sabemos si tenemos
que usar seno o coseno bueno el seno
empieza en cero y va hacia arriba
mientras que el coche no empieza en el
máximo y después va hacia abajo entonces
si conocemos el comportamiento de
nuestro oscilador cuando
es igual a cero podremos saber si
usaremos seno o cosenos y también es muy
importante saber cómo encontrar el
periodo de un oscilador miren el periodo
de una masa colgada en el resorte es
igual a dos pi por la raíz cuadrada de
la masa colgada en el resorte entre la
constante de elasticidad que ahora
observen que esta ecuación no depende de
la amplitud entonces si estiramos el
resorte llevando la masa lo más lejos
posible el resorte se regresará más
rápido y entre más lo estiramos el
periodo será constante pero ahora la
fórmula para el periodo de un péndulo
que es una masa balanceándose en una
cuerda es igual a dos pi por la raíz
cuadrada de la longitud de la cuerda
entre la magnitud de la aceleración
causada por la gravedad y esto tampoco
depende de la amplitud mientras que los
ángulos sean pequeños y tampoco depende
de la masa pero como encontramos el
periodo en una graf
y bueno si les dan la gráfica del
movimiento de un oscilador armónico
simple en función del tiempo el
intervalo entre las crestas representa
el periodo o el tiempo en el que el
oscilador se reinicia veamos un ejemplo
supongamos que en un experimento una
masa m en la tierra puede ser colgada en
un resorte de longitud l provocando que
oscile de un lado a otro con un periodo
t del péndulo o puede ser colgada en un
resorte con una constante está
provocando que oscile arriba y abajo con
un periodo de del resorte y si en lugar
de m usamos una masa 12 m qué pasa con
el periodo de los dos movimientos bueno
el periodo de un péndulo no depende de
la masa por lo tanto el periodo del
péndulo no cambia y la respuesta es la
opción de que son las ondas las ondas
mecánicas son una alteración que viaja
por un medio y que transfiere energía y
momento a través de distancia significa
sin transmitir ninguna masa y que es un
medio un medio es cualquier material por
el que puede viajar una onda y podemos
clasificar a las ondas según el medio
por el que se propaga pero también
podemos clasificar a las ondas según el
tipo de perturbación que crean por
ejemplo en las ondas transversales la
oscilación del medio es perpendicular a
la velocidad de la onda y con velocidad
de la onda me refiero a la dirección en
la que viaja la perturbación y con
oscilación del medio me refiero a la
dirección en la que las partículas del
medio se mueve por ejemplo para una onda
en una cuerda las partículas se mueven
arriba y abajo pero la perturbación se
mueve hacia la derecha esa sería una
onda transversal mientras que en una
onda longitudinal la oscilación o
perturbación del medio es paralela a la
velocidad de la onda y una onda
longitudinal muy conocida es el sonido
la onda sonora viaja de esta forma se ve
como una región comprimida y él
aire se mueve de un lado a otro de
derecha a izquierda paralelo a la
dirección en la que se mueven las ondas
sonoras haciendo que las ondas sonoras
sean longitudinales ahora para cada tipo
de onda la velocidad de onda es igual a
la longitud de onda entre el periodo de
oscilación entonces si observamos la
cresta de una onda podemos ver que se
mueve una longitud de onda por periodo y
como la velocidad es igual la distancia
entre tiempo la velocidad de una onda es
igual a la longitud de onda entre el
periodo y podemos calcular la longitud
de onda en una gráfica versus x al
calcular la distancia entre las crestas
y bueno si se preguntan por qué esto no
representa el periodo eso es porque esta
es una gráfica en función de x la
posición horizontal no del tiempo y en
una gráfica de que contra el tiempo se
representa el movimiento de un solo
punto en la onda para todos los momentos
en el tiempo y en
la gráfica contra el tiempo el intervalo
entre las crestas es el periodo entonces
sí gráfica mos una onda tenemos que
revisar si está en función de x o de t
si es que contra x la distancia de
cresta cresta es la longitud de onda
pero si es que contrate la distancia de
cresta cresta es el periodo y como 1
entre el periodo es igual a la
frecuencia podemos reescribir la
ecuación de la velocidad como velocidad
de onda igual a la longitud de onda por
la frecuencia que también la pueden
encontrar como longitud de onda igual a
la velocidad de onda entre la frecuencia
ahora a veces esta fórmula confunde a
muchas personas porque piensan que si
incrementamos la frecuencia también
aumenta la velocidad de onda pero en
realidad incrementar la frecuencia
provoca que la longitud de onda
disminuya y la velocidad de honda
permanecerá constante pues la única
forma de cambiar la velocidad de una
onda es cambiando las propiedades
medio es decir que la única forma de
cambiar la velocidad de las ondas no sé
por ejemplo en el agua es cambiando algo
del agua como por ejemplo su densidad o
su salinidad o su temperatura pero
cambiar la frecuencia o la amplitud no
cambiará la velocidad de la onda veamos
un ejemplo supongamos que en un cuarto
con un volumen total b y una temperatura
t una bocina se conecta a un generador
de funciones y emite una nota con una
frecuencia f y una amplitud a cuál de
las siguientes opciones podría cambiar
la velocidad de las ondas sonoras bueno
aumentar la frecuencia sólo aumentará el
tono del sonido pero no cambiará la
velocidad de la onda ahora aumentar la
temperatura del cuarto es un cambio al
medio por lo tanto esto sí cambiará la
velocidad del sonido mientras que
disminuir la amplitud
sólo hará que el sonido sea más suave y
no suene tan alto y disminuir el volumen
total del espacio del cuarto
no afecta mucho porque es solo disminuye
el medio así que la mejor respuesta es
la opción ve el efecto doppler se
refiere al cambio de la frecuencia
percibida cuando una bocina o una fuente
de ondas se mueve en relación al
observador si la fuente y el observador
se mueven uno hacia el otro la longitud
de onda disminuye de acuerdo a este
observador por lo que la frecuencia
percibida aumenta y esto ocurre porque
la fuente se encuentra hacia el
observador y conforme la bocina emite
pulsaciones de onda en este límite las
crestas de las ondas estarán muy cerca
así que la longitud de onda será pequeña
y la velocidad a la que esas crestas
alcanzarán al observador serán mayores
por lo que este observador escuchará una
frecuencia más alta de la que en
realidad emite la fuente cuando está en
reposo y para el caso del observador de
este lado como las ondas se alejan de la
fuente aquí la longitud de onda será
mayor por lo que
disminuye la velocidad de onda entonces
este observador escuchará una frecuencia
menor a la que en realidad emite la
fuente cuando está en reposo veamos un
ejemplo supongamos que el conductor de
un coche se da cuenta de que se dirige
hacia una persona que está detenida en
un paso peatonal así que toca la bocina
continuamente y emite un sonido de
frecuencia efe esta es la frecuencia de
la bocina que se emite cuando el coche
se encuentra en reposo y simultáneamente
el conductor frena de golpe y se patina
justo frente a la persona que está
inmóvil en el paso peatonal que escuchó
la persona en el paso peatonal cuando el
coche se patinó bueno como el coche se
dirige hacia la persona las crestas de
las ondas sonoras empiezan muy cerca
entre ellas así que esta persona escucha
una longitud de onda pequeña y una
frecuencia de onda más alta pero
conforme el coche desacelera este
2 se vuelve menos dramático y una vez
que el coche se detiene las ondas se
separan y la persona escucha la
frecuencia normal de la bocina del coche
así que primero la persona escucho una
frecuencia más alta a la de la bocina
pero eventualmente fue igual a la
frecuencia de la bocina porque una vez
que el coche se detuvo ya no existía
movimiento entre la persona y el coche
cuando dos ondas se traslapan en el
mismo medio a eso se le conoce como
interferencia o superposición de ondas y
mientras que las ondas se superponen se
combinan para formar una onda que es la
suma de las dos ondas es decir que
mientras las dos ondas se superponen
para calcular el valor de la onda total
simplemente hay que sumar los valores de
las ondas individuales entonces si se
superponen dos ondas que son muy
parecidas se combinarán para formar una
onda total que será el doble de grande y
a eso se le conoce como interferencia
constructiva pero si se superpone
dos ondas que se encuentran desfasadas
180 grados no formaran ninguna onda y a
eso se le conoce como interferencia
destructiva y aun cuando las ondas se
superponen y que podemos usar los
valores de las ondas individuales para
conocer el valor de la onda total
después de que estas ondas se superponen
no pasan una sobre la otra por ejemplo
si en una cuerda enviamos un pulso de
onda como este y también este cuando los
dos pulsos se sobrepongan la cuerda se
verá plana pero un poco después los
pulsos continuarán su camino sin ningún
cambio pues no tendrá ninguna relación
solo mientras existen superpuestas
existirá la interferencia veamos un
ejemplo supongamos que dos pulsos de
ondas se mueven uno hacia el otro como
se muestra en esta imagen de la derecha
y queremos saber cuál será la forma de
la onda cuando los pulsos se superponga
bueno para encontrar la onda total
necesitamos agregar los valores de cada
a onda individual y miren la onda azul
se mueve hacia la derecha y la onda roja
se mueve hacia la izquierda y al sumar
los valores de las ondas individuales
aquí tenemos 0 en la onda roja más menos
dos unidades de la onda azul eso nos da
menos 2 y después tenemos 2 unidades en
la onda roja más menos 2 unidades en la
onda azul eso es igual a 0 unidades para
la onda total después otra vez tenemos 2
más menos 20 y finalmente tenemos 0
unidades de la onda roja más menos dos
unidades de la onda azul eso nos da
menos dos unidades para la onda total
por lo tanto la onda total se ve así la
onda roja se come un poquito de la onda
azul como podemos trabajar con las ondas
estacionarias en una cuerda bueno para
tener una onda estacionaria necesitamos
ondas que se superpongan pero que además
vayan en direcciones opuestas pero
cuando tengamos eso no necesariamente
obtendremos una onda estacionaria porque
solo ciertas longitudes de onda crean
una onda estacionaria en un medio y lo
que determina la longitud de onda es la
longitud del medio y los límites de ese
medio y miren los extremos de una cuerda
se pueden fijar o dejar sueltos si el
extremo está fijo habrá nodos de
desplazamiento nodo es la palabra que
usamos para referirnos a dos puntos que
no se mueve pero si los extremos de la
cuerda están sueltos entonces actúan
como anti nodos y un anti nodo es un
punto que tiene un movimiento o mejor
dicho desplazamiento máximo y como se
ven las ondas estacionarias bueno las
ondas estacionarias no parecen moverse a
lo largo del medio solo oscilan de un
lado a otro por ejemplo este nodo se
moverá de arriba a abajo y de regreso
pero no veremos que esta cresta se mueva
hacia la derecha o hacia la izquierda
por eso se llaman ondas estacionarias
además de que los nodos
permanecen en su lugar no hay un
desplazamiento y bueno una vez que
determinamos las condiciones y la
longitud del medio se pueden establecer
las posibles longitudes de onda en este
caso las únicas son las estacionarias
permitidas empiezan en nodo y terminan
en nodo y miren la onda estacionaria
fundamental corresponde a la longitud
más larga posible y en este caso será de
un medio de la longitud de onda
entonces la longitud del medio es igual
a un medio de la longitud de onda y de
forma similar para el segundo armónico
también empezamos y terminamos en nodo
pero la siguiente posibilidad es una
longitud de onda completa eso significa
que la longitud del medio es igual a la
longitud de onda y si pasamos al tercer
armónico esto corresponde a tres medios
de la longitud de onda y no hay límite
podemos seguir aumentando la frecuencia
porque seguimos disminuyendo la longitud
de onda es decir la distancia entre las
crestas pero
como se verá una onda estacionaria
cuando sólo uno de los extremos de la
cuerda está fijo bueno en ese caso uno
de los extremos es un anti nodo y la
onda estacionaria fundamental solo toma
la forma de un cuarto de la longitud de
onda pues va de un nodo a un anti nodo
eso significa que la longitud es igual a
un cuarto de la longitud de onda la
siguiente onda estacionaria posible es
de tres cuartos de la longitud de onda y
la siguiente posibilidad es de cinco
cuartos de la longitud de onda y así
consecutivamente veamos un ejemplo
supongamos que uno de los extremos de
una cuerda de longitud dl está fijo a la
pared y el otro extremo está unido a una
barra vibratoria un estudiante se da
cuenta de que la cuerda crea una onda
estacionaria como se muestra aquí
entonces cuando la frecuencia de la
barra se ajusta a efe 0 cual es la
velocidad de las ondas de la cuerda
bueno sabemos que la longitud de la
cuerda
es el y sabemos que desde aquí hasta
aquí es una longitud de onda y después
tenemos un medio así que la longitud de
la cuerda l es igual a tres medios de la
longitud de onda es decir que la
longitud de onda es 12 l entre 3 y
sabemos que la velocidad de onda siempre
es igual a la longitud de onda por la
frecuencia por lo tanto la velocidad de
onda para este caso es igual a 12 l
entre 3 que es la longitud de onda por
la frecuencia así que la mejor respuesta
es la opción de cómo podemos trabajar
con ondas estacionarias en tubos bueno
es como con las ondas estacionarias en
una cuerda la longitud de onda se
determina con la longitud del tubo y las
condiciones de los extremos pero esta
vez en lugar de una cuerda vamos a crear
ondas estacionarias con las ondas
sonoras ahora para las condiciones de
los extremos de un tubo si los extremos
están abiertos decimos que actúan como
anti nudos
desplazamiento ya que el aire en un
extremo abierto puede oscilar mucho y
así es como obtenemos una perturbación
máxima de aire pero un extremo cerrado
actúa como un nodo de desplazamiento por
lo que en este caso no hay perturbación
de aire ahora si los dos extremos del
tubo están abiertos obtenemos una onda
estacionaria anti nodo anti nodo y la
primera posibilidad para la longitud de
onda que va desde este anti nodo a este
que es la mitad de la longitud de onda
es la mitad de la longitud de onda así
que la longitud de este tubo es igual a
la mitad de la longitud de onda la
siguiente posibilidad también va de anti
nodo anti nodos pero esto es igual a una
longitud de onda entera tal vez no
parezca pero recuerden que de valle a
valle hay una longitud de onda por lo
tanto la longitud de este tubo es igual
a la longitud de onda y la siguiente
posibilidad es igual a tres medios de la
longitud de onda
observen que esta es la misma secuencia
que teníamos en el caso de las ondas
estacionarias de nodo a nodo en una
cuerda entonces si los dos extremos son
anti nodos o nodos es decir si las
condiciones de los dos extremos son
iguales obtendremos la misma secuencia
un medio de la longitud de onda una
longitud de onda tres medios de la
longitud de onda y así consecutivamente
pero qué pasaría si cerramos uno de los
extremos del tubo bueno si cerramos uno
de los extremos del tubo ese extremo
actúa como un nodo de desplazamiento ya
que el aire no se puede mover en ese
punto así que pasamos de un nodo a un
anti nodo que es un extremo abierto por
lo tanto para este caso la primera
posibilidad es que la longitud del tubo
es igual a un cuarto de la longitud de
onda y si se dan cuenta esto es lo mismo
que teníamos en el caso de la cuerda que
iba de nodo a anti nodo es la misma
secuencia lambda entre 4
3 lambda entre 45 lambda entre 4
entonces si uno de los extremos tiene
una condición diferente esta será la
secuencia para la longitud del medio
veamos un ejemplo supongamos que al
soplar sobre la parte superior de un
tubo abierto por los dos lados el aire
resuena con una frecuencia f 0 pero si
ahora la parte inferior del tubo está
cerrada y el aire sopla nuevamente hacia
la parte superior del tubo qué
frecuencia se escucha en relación a la
frecuencia que teníamos cuando los dos
extremos estaban abiertos bueno si los
dos extremos están abiertos sabemos que
la onda estacionaria será una onda que
va de anti nodo a anti nodo y eso es un
medio de la longitud de onda que es
igual a la longitud del tubo por lo
tanto la longitud de onda es igual a 2
por la longitud del tubo pero cuando
cerramos uno de los extremos ahora este
extremo es 12 entonces ahora
de nodo anti nota y eso es un cuarto de
la longitud de onda y eso es igual a la
longitud del tubo por lo tanto lambda es
igual a 4 l es el doble pero eso como
afecta a la frecuencia bueno sabemos que
b es igual a lambda por efe y aquí no
cambiamos el medio por lo tanto la
velocidad permanece constante entonces
si duplicamos la longitud de onda
la frecuencia tiene que disminuir a la
mitad para que se mantenga la misma
velocidad de onda así que cuando
cerramos uno de los extremos del tubo
escuchamos la mitad de la frecuencia que
habíamos escuchado cuando los dos
extremos estaban abiertos
la frecuencia de oscilación se refiere
al fenómeno en el que dos ondas de
diferentes frecuencias se superponen y
cuando eso sucede la interferencia de
las ondas en un punto dado en el espacio
pasa de constructiva a destructiva y
nuevamente a constructiva y así
sucesivamente y si esto fuera una onda
ahora se puede percibir como un tambaleo
un cambio en el volumen del sonido y eso
es porque si estas ondas empiezan en
fase y había una interferencia
constructiva como tienen frecuencias
diferentes una de las ondas empieza a
desplazarse hasta que en algún momento
la interferencia se vuelve destructiva
con lo que el sonido será suave pero si
esperamos un poco una de las crestas
volverá a coincidir y la interferencia
volverá a ser constructiva con lo que el
volumen del sonido aumenta y al tiempo
que tarda en las ondas en pasar de un
volumen alto a uno bajo o suave y de
nuevo a uno alto se le conoce como
periodo de oscilación aunque puede que
estén más familiarizados con la
frecuencia de oscilación que simplemente
es igual a uno entre el periodo de
oscilación entonces el periodo de
oscilación es el tiempo que tarda una
onda en pasar por todo esto mientras que
la frecuencia de oscilación es el número
de veces que es
ocurre por segundo y como podemos
calcular la frecuencia de oscilación o
el periodo de oscilación bueno la
fórmula que usamos para calcular la
frecuencia de oscilación es muy sencilla
es igual a la resta de las frecuencias
de las dos sondas que se superponen y si
no hay una diferencia es decir si las
ondas tienen la misma frecuencia
tendremos una frecuencia de oscilación
igual a cero con lo que no escucharemos
ningún cambio en el volumen es decir
ningún tambaleó pero entre más
diferentes sean estas frecuencias más
tambaleos escucharemos por segundo y
para calcular el periodo de oscilación
simplemente dividimos uno entre la
frecuencia veamos un ejemplo supongamos
que estas dos ondas se superponen y
queremos saber cuál es la frecuencia de
oscilación bueno el periodo de la
primera onda es de cuatro segundos eso
significa que la frecuencia de la
primera onda es uno entre cuatro o
también 0.25 hertz
el período de la segunda onda es de dos
segundos eso significa que la frecuencia
es igual a uno entre dos o también 0.5
hertz así que para calcular la
frecuencia de oscilación simplemente
recitamos las frecuencias y 0.5 menos
0.25 es igual a 0.25 hertz